hi I'm Lea Manuel Miranda I'm here for
Mary Poppins returns I'm answering your
fan questions and look at this guy I'll
be playing with puppies the whole time
oh I'm excited for her audiences to see
the continuing Adventures of Mary
Poppins to see Michael and Jane Banks
all grown and and Marc Shaiman and Scott
Whitman's incredible songs I feel like
the best thing they did was get the
biggest super fan of the original film
Rob Marshall to direct it because I
think that everything in here will make
fans of the original very happy I think
the dancing I think I was pretty funny
baby I think I was pretty daunted by
step in time in the original and we've
got a number that's about as long and as
elaborate as that and so it was the
lastingly film and it was about six
months of rehearsal for it and at the
same time the level of mastery going
from just learning how to swing around a
lamppost and then suddenly you're
holding a flaming stick and there's BMX
bikers all around you getting to that
level of mastery this was pretty
satisfying right oh they're totally
different skill sets you know acting on
stage as a yoga it's seven times a week
eight times a week and you're gonna hit
the same marks every night but the
audience changes your performance your
energy that day changes your performance
and your relationship to your fellow
actors on screen you're never coming
back to Buckingham Palace you're never
coming back to Big Bend so the
adrenaline do you like really comes from
knowing that that's your chance mr.
Chester did it right
yeah surely well well there's two things
we actually I think I've said this but
we've we filmed the original company
about a week before the first cast
members started leaving and Tommy Kael
made an amazing movie out of it and we
stuck it in a vault and it's in a
basement in somewhere so at some point
you'll see that so if you have an
obnoxious friend who is bragging or so
the original company that brag is gonna
be out of use at some point you will see
them you just haven't decided when you
know I want as many people to get to see
it live in the original format in which
it was intended the theater before we
release it but we've got it it's a green
God's fault
what's his puppy's name guppy oh my
goodness I'm holding Dudley I'm getting
licked by a real cute puppy oh wow
we are just jamming Jesus Oh his breath
smells like salmon now he's biting up on
my finger doesn't really hurt I will not
let it linger
he's got puppy teeth then they are not
sharp I will not go to heaven I am NOT
playing a harp you can gnaw on that it
does not hurt my pinky after this I'll
have a big gin and tonic drinky Brooklyn
language my favorite chef I hope so I'm
glad NBC picked it back up I don't think
I was but I was a loud part of it
[Music]
oh that's a fantastic question I don't
know the answer to that either I think
we'll find out you know my favorite
character was always Sebastian he's
really misunderstood composer everyone
forgets that but he's the court composer
and suddenly he's babysitting the 16
year old and man that is so relatable
for me you know we're still very much in
script development things on on Little
Mermaid so if there needs to be a new
song I'm happy to write lyrics for Alan
Menken so it doesn't need to be because
that score is perfect I don't think I'm
gonna tell you the answer that because I
would want to surprise you total eclipse
of the heart and or I would do anything
for love but I won't do that
it's very indulgent to take the mic for
seven minutes what I say I would say
it's a long story you're gonna be mad
about some of this and maybe some of it
you like but I had you win against
Jefferson a lot oh that changes every
day it's funny right now I'm relearning
all my lines because I'm getting ready
to play Hamilton in Puerto Rico the one
that's really fun for me that I'm proud
of right now because I'm relearning it
is um farmer refuted where Hamilton is
literally rhyming at the same time the
Samuel see Barry while he verbally
destroying him that's pretty fun to play
[Music]
I'm much more Zen about rejection
because now I've been on the other side
of the auditioning table and I realize
how little of it has to do with your
talent and how much of it has to do with
the very specific needs of that casting
director or that director in that moment
and so you can't take it personally
because you might be the wrong height
you might have the wrong hair color and
and then the other thing I will tell
people is that you have to think of
auditioning as the job it's not getting
the job auditioning is the job if you
get the job great
but auditioning is actually the job no a
toad at all I remember I rhymed it with
my uncle he's a janitor that was one
where the creators of the show basically
wrote and then Lin does an incredible
rhyme an incredible 16 bars about Canada
and rhymes it perfectly and left it up
to me to write so that was a fun
assignment it was it was really fun I
love those guys
oh I miss messed up and broken inside as
everybody else but I am well aware
just like you publishers that you get
what you put out into the world so I try
when I'm tweeting which is a terrible
addiction of mine to just sort of try to
put out what I would like to see I read
the same news articles as you I see the
same horrors I wake up with the same
morning breath but I try if I'm having a
terrible day not to put the terrible out
into the world that makes sense these
puppies were provided by Vanderpump dogs
and you can't hear because they're
chewing my mic record if for more
information on these beautiful puppies
go to Vanderpump it dogs don't work
[Music]